tu te dit tout
message au tiff où les transitions comme
ça je pense à havre dans tous les sens
ouais
en plus c'est facile à faire il n'y a
rien à installer sa marche sur final cut
sur premiere pro sur ce que vous voulez
et accessoirement c'est gratos ba
aujourd'hui je vous montre comment je
fais
[Musique]
et saluer tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore je
suis ravi de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui je vous
demande une technique très simple pour
faire tout plein de transition ultra
stylée et avec cette seule technique
vous allez pouvoir décliner le truc à
l'infini sans rien installer sans rien
acheter sans rien payer à condition
d'avoir un logiciel de montage digne de
ce nom un final cut première cros
davinci voilà d'ailleurs
exceptionnellement aujourd'hui on va
aussi voir comment ça fonctionne avec
première mais oui et c'est technique
c'est tout simplement la rampe de
vélocité un speedrun en anglais en gros
ça consiste à accélérer ou à ralentir un
plan progressivement d'ailleurs je vous
en avais parlé dans une précédente vidéo
mais pas pour les transitions donc vous
allez voir qu'on peut détourner un truc
pour faire des transitions ultra
créative comme vous avez pu le voir au
tout début de la vidéo je vais pas
attendre plus longtemps
voyons tout de suite comment on s'y
prend il ya deux parties essentielles
dans la réalisation de cette transition
la première elle va se passer au
tournage la seconde au montage
je vous explique dans cet exemple les
deux plans s'enchaînent pas seulement à
cause de la transition mais aussi à
cause du mouvement de caméra qui a été
réalisé lors du tournage et précisément
dans cet exemple là j'ai joué un petit
peu avec les rotations de grosso modo ça
qu'on cite avec votre caméra quand vous
filmez à faire des petits trucs comme ça
ou alors même en avance en
contre-plongée bref tourner un petit peu
le machin dans tous les sens assez
lentement quand même de manière assez
fluide pour avoir quelque chose qui me
tente pas trop on va pas secouer
l'appareil dans tous les sens mais dans
ces extraits ben moi j'ai fait des trucs
à peu près comme ça ou en avançant bref
des choses où ça tourne un minime et du
coup avant même d'aller parler de
montage le truc super importante pour
ces choses-là et de manière générale
quand on va souhaiter quelque chose
c'est l'anticipation il va falloir
anticiper un minimum ce que vous allez
shooter parce que s'il n'y a pas de
mouvements de caméra et des mouvements
de caméra qui match eh ben il n'y a pas
de transition alors que s'il ya des
mouvements de caméra réfléchi et
anticipé non seulement il ya des
transitions mais en plus elles vont être
vachement cool alors donc ici bas j'ai
tous mes plans qui sont en vitesse
réelle
et là ça donne pas grand chose mais on
voit bien quand même toutes les
rotations le truc c'est que je vais déjà
tous les sélectionnés allez cliquer ici
sur le bouton pour gérer la vitesse et
cliquez sur vitesses automatique et vu
que j'ai filmé en sans images par
secondes je me retrouve avec des
fichiers ralenti comme ça je vais bien
pouvoir jouer avec les accélérations
alors maintenant je vais
et sélectionnez le premier plan et je
vais utiliser le raccourci clavier shift
b qui va me permettre de faire un genre
de kuyt qui en est pas vraiment un c'est
un cut uniquement dans la vitesse et en
plus de ça entre la première partie qui
va être une vitesse et la deuxième
partie qui va être à une autre je vais
avoir une progressivité
d'où le nom rappelé de vélocité donc
j'ai laissé la première partie en
vitesse lente comme elle est telle
qu'elle est la deuxième partie je vais
aller cliquer sur accéléré et sur x 20
première partie tchèque
ensuite j'ai tout simplement les refaire
la même chose sur le second plan et
c'est sur la partie du début que je vais
cliquez sur rapide et accélérer x 20
taden on a notre rotation notre
transition on n'a rien vu parce que les
les deux parties sont accélérées et les
deux parties sont en mouvement donc
c'est passé comme une lettre à la poste
comme dans du bois comme papa dans maman
c'est dégueulasse je sais pas si je vais
le garder au montage son et après ça
juste la cerise sur le gâteau il restera
plus qu'à rajouter un petit peu de 5
design avec un an sont de mouches là
pour faire le petit et puis c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça alors attention
quand vous faites votre découpage dites
vous que la partie que vous allez
accéléré elle va être considérablement
réduite donc prenez un bon morceau un
bon gros morceau où il ya du mouvement
de dents pour pouvoir leur ralentir
après et dites vous que la partie que
vous laisser tel quel c'est la partie
que vous allez voir
alors que la partie accéléré elle va
faire plus ou moins partie de la
transition et elle va pas être forcément
visible et maintenant je montre une
deuxième déclinaison de ce type de
transition avec d'autres mouvements vous
allez voir est alors ici ce que j'ai
voulu faire c'est jouer avec
le tissu qui volaient qu'ils aient un
effet très joli et c'était sûr ça que je
voulais axé ma transition ont fait plus
que sur le mouvement donc j'ai pris deux
mouvements qui sont à peu près random il
y en a un qui va sur le côté et y en a
un qui va vers le haut donc
techniquement c'est pas censé match et
mais comme il ya au milieu cet élément
bleu du tissu qui qui ondule dans l'air
au ralenti bien vous allez voir que le
fait d'avoir ces deux mouvements qui
sont pas censés match et est bas au
final ça match même principe je vais me
placer sur le premier plan shift b
j'accélère la fin le second plan schiff
b et j'accélère le début alors ce coup
ci c'est de ne pas ça donne un espèce de
voilà on sait pas trop ce qui s'est
passé mais ça s'est passé et essai et
c'est beau voilà ces jolies femmes
moi je trouve ça joli je pourrais aussi
vous montrer cet extrait là que vous
avez pas vu au début où là va tout
simplement j'avais mon appareil sur un
stabilisateur et j'ai avancé dans
différentes allait rester dans un garage
et j'ai tout simplement répéter la même
opération sert que j'ai coupé rentrer de
vélocité à la fin un plan en deux
félicités au début du plan suivant et là
j'ai carrément voulu les enchaînés
puisse y en avait plusieurs y avait
plein d'aller et du coup on fait rome de
vélocité au début et à la fin du plan et
ensuite tout s'enchaîne ça passe comme
voilà comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça
passe crème
ouais je sais vous allez me dire oui
mais tu avais dit qu'on verrait sur
première oui on va voir ce première mais
pour ça je vais laisser la parole à
quelqu'un qui gère vachement bien
première victoire c'est à toi est lié
leur ci prend soin salut à tous et
victor ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on passe sur premiere pro pour que je
vous montre le tuto du spi tram sur
premiere pro comme ça vous avez eu la
version final cut
et si vous montez sur première fois vous
avez la version première procès parties
la première chose à faire est d'afficher
leur mappage temporel de vos clips pour
pouvoir ajuster la vitesse graduellement
ensuite il vous suffit de sélectionner à
l'endroit où vous voulez que la vitesse
s'accélère vous appuyez sur la touche
paix de votre clavier et vous augmentez
la vitesse de votre clip à la vitesse
désirée
ensuite il vous suffit d'ajuster que ce
soit graduelle et puis faire la même
chose sur le deuxième clip au début du
clip cette fois-ci vous les assemblées
et le tour est joué
donc voilà j'espère que ce tuto vous
aura été utile pour ma part je repasse
la parole à françois et puis je vous dis
à très bientôt
salut merci à toi victor et si vous
voulez découvrir sa chaîne va vous allez
dans la description je vous mettrai le
lien il fait des vidéos super cool en
conclusion avec cette technique de
rendre de vélocité bas vous allez
pouvoir créer toute une infinité en fait
deux déclinaisons de ce type de
transition surtout vous allez éviter
d'utiliser des plugins ou d'acheter des
effets pour les transitions et avoir
quelque chose de beaucoup plus personnel
au final alors faut pas en abuser non
plus faut pas en être tout le temps je
vous ai montré un extrait de 15 secondes
dans les vidéo complète il n'ya pas
chaque transition n'est pas une rampe de
vélocité un bon petit que de temps en
temps ou d'autres types de transition ça
peut être très bien il faudra le doser
avec parcimonie par siki parcimonie
l'idée c'est de nous personnalisé de le
faire à votre sauce de faire votre pâte
et vous avez vu que c'est vraiment pas
compliquer le tout c'est d'anticiper
avant de réfléchir ses plans et de
manière générale quand on part ajouté
anticiper et prévoir ses plans c'est
souvent synonyme d'une vidéo réussi puis
quand je le disais un ca coute rien ça
bouffe pas de ressources sur
l'ordinateur c'est pas des plugins de
tarés bref la vie est belle ou quoi et
voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas à mettre le traditionnel coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
pensez à vous abonner
si c'est pas déjà fait laissez moi un
petit message ça fait toujours plaisir
si vous avez d'autres transitions a
suggéré dans les commentaires il n'y a
pas de souci ça m'intéresse toujours de
savoir ce que vous pensez et qu'on
puisse échanger et partager tous autour
de ces vidéos et surtout surtout si vous
voulez aider n'hésitez pas à partager
cette vidéo à en parler autour de vous
c'est ça qui aide le plus voilà pouces
bleus commentaires partage compte sur
vous les amis et en attendant jeu
comme d'habitude rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
mais moi les lieux
moi j'aime ça quand ça part dans tous
les sens j'aime ça quand ça casse mais
voilà où tous les sens partout partout
sa part voilà moi j'ai une moyenne et et
vol